- (crowd cheering) She is
featured on this month's
cover of Health magazine,
and it's the first unretouched cover
in the magazine's
history. (crowd cheering)
So let's talk about your part there.
I mean is it hard?
Because everything nowadays is so filtered
and so retouched.
Was it hard and scary,
especially six months after having a baby?
- It was so scary.
And leading up I was still breastfeeding
when I did the shoot.
And I was just freaking
out the whole time.
- And that part was probably good,
'cause they're real full. (laughs)
- Oh, I didn't need the help.
- Some of us do Kate. (both laughing)
- Something like, I
didn't need any extra, no.
But you know?
Unretouched is actually
really part for everybody
on set I noticed like, the makeup artist,
the hairstylist, everyone's like,
"Oh my God, what are we
gonna do with her bruise
"on her knee?
"Who's gonna cover it?
"The makeup is not covering it!"
Everything's very stressful.
And doing it in natural lighting,
adds that very real element as well.
- Boy, natural lighting is not
my friend. (crowd laughing)
I like it nice soft amber dim light.
- [Kate] That's such a
lie, stop! (laughing)
No, but it was really
important for me to do this.
Because we're on Instagram all the time,
and we see people
Photoshopping everything.
You know like, when does it end?
When you're scrolling on Instagram,
you constantly compare
yourself to these other people.
And for me, I wanted us
to like take a set back
and show a real moment of
someone who actually is
a six months post-partum,
is not being Photoshop.
And be that real person and real influence
for other people.
- I love it!
I think it's awesome. (clapping)